the plant-based diet is abundant in
nutrients as long as you're choosing a
large variety of fruits veggies whole
grains beans nuts seeds tofu tempeh all
of those incredible ingredients you're
going to get everything that you need
[Music]
the health benefits that i've seen in my
patients in the short term and the long
term and what we see in the data as well
show us that a plant rich and even a
plant exclusive diet is brilliantly
healthy
[Music]
greetings internet welcome to the
podcast
today we're back talking diet talking
nutrition and overall well-being with an
additional focus on hormone health
particularly but not exclusively
women's hormone health and we're going
to do it with dr gemma newman
gemma is a graduate of the university of
wales college of medicine she has
expertise in a variety of specialties
and serves as a senior partner at a
family medicine practice in the uk
she is also the author of the
plant-powered doctor a primer on the
power of plant-based nutrition to
prevent and reverse many common chronic
illnesses from diabetes and heart
disease to obesity
as well as the science that explains why
it works
gemma first appeared on the show almost
exactly three years ago rrp 449 it was
quite a popular episode in case you
missed it and today she's back to get
granular on the relationship between
nutrition and hormones with a focus but
again not an exclusive focus on women
we talk endometriosis
fibroids menopause
testosterone replacement therapy
important foods nutrients and
supplements to best balance our hormones
and many other topics
it's worth pointing out that i learned
quite a bit from this conversation it's
not just for the women out there plenty
of valuable information for everybody so
do me a huge favor take a beat and
quickly hit that subscribe button and
notification bell you see right down
there in the right hand corner
thank you very much and enjoy this
conversation with the wise and wonderful
dr gemma newman
we're here we're doing it yeah it took a
minute didn't it it did you were
supposed to come something like six
months ago
yeah but then
richard got coveted yeah yeah
so that got delayed and then i wasn't
sure if you were ever gonna make it out
but here you are i'm so delighted to sit
with you today i'm delighted to be here
i really am i haven't been to la in
nearly 20 years um
so it's been wow yeah well you picked a
nice moment we had some rain the other
day which was very unusual but
everything's uncharacteristically green
you must feel very you know
much like it's it feels like this is the
ireland time of year it will quickly
turn brown but right now it's pretty
great it is i was we were driving here
this morning and i thought wow this
looks so
british there's so much green i know
really surprised yeah yeah yeah well we
did it just for you gemma to make you
feel at home
um
and i was trying to remember the last
time i saw you was it at the retreat or
was it when i was in one i can't
remember i mean everything's a blur
because of covid yeah i think the
pandemic changes and warps time slightly
for sure probably at the retreat because
i saw you in london between
that and the last time order of events
the order i get i don't remember what
came before what but anyway
you are here lots of stuff to talk about
um
and because
the first time you were on the show
was many years ago and also because it
was recorded at the retreat in kind of a
fireside format i think it would be
helpful and instructive to just sort of
introduce yourself your background a
little bit and this journey that you've
been on that led you to being this
advocate for the plant-based lifestyle
okay
so
i've been a doctor now for
oh
18 years and i always knew i wanted to
be a doctor i felt that very strongly
from a young age
but in my medical training i think it's
fair to say i didn't necessarily look
after myself a lot of late nights a lot
of studying and then when i went into
actually being a doctor again there was
loads of night shifts and does anyone
look after themselves as a medical
student or as a young doctor i mean
there's really not a lot of room for
that probably no that would be an
unusual outlier case i would think
you're right i think it would be and
although
there is i don't know what it's like in
the u.s but in the uk you know there is
time for sports and stuff like that sort
of recreational stuff
but i didn't really partake of that i
was a real bookworm and
yeah i partied as well of course but
i think it's safe to say that my focus
was not my health then like you say most
doctors at that stage don't really focus
on health too much which is ironic
um
but i felt like when i started work
something had to change because i was
exhausted all the time
and i was falling asleep i was coming
home from late shifts
and i thought i can't be doing this job
for the rest of my life whilst feeling
this way so i knew something had to
change and at that time i hadn't done a
great deal of research
i just thought well
i will
calorie count i will exercise and i will
cut the carbs because that's what the
background hum was telling me to do
in med school i learned about
nutritional deficiencies i learned
pathology and anatomy and communication
skills and lots of other things but not
a great deal about wellness nutrition
so
fast forward i did brilliantly with that
i got my energy back i felt great i was
proud of myself
then i realized to my dismay that i
still had risk factors for heart disease
i checked my lipid profiles and they
were still raised and i thought back
then there was nothing i could do about
it that it was just genetic it was my
destiny and i'd have to cope with that
later in
life and then fast forward a few years
my husband richard introduced me to your
book finding ultra oh yeah that's right
i forgot about that yeah yeah and he was
running a marathon he was doing
initially quite badly he was getting
inflamed injured
and then he decided after reading your
book and a few others that he'd go
plant-based
and that was my first introduction to
plant-based living
um i was skeptical i know we talked
about this before but i i watched
closely with skepticism
he did brilliantly his next marathon
training run he did like an hour and ten
minutes faster that got me really
interested not from an athletic point of
view i have done a couple of marathons
myself but i i wouldn't call myself
someone that's particularly athletic or
focused on performance for me it was
about my patience so were were you on
board eating that way also in tandem
with him or you were just observing him
doing that and making mental notes yes
skeptical mental notes yeah i was
observing
i didn't actually so two different two
different types of of meals happening in
the household yeah that's right he was
cooking for himself for a while and i
was just watching and
learning
and you know don't get me wrong i had
already read a little bit about the
environmental side of plant-based living
after he
introduced me to your book and a couple
of others so i knew that there were some
definite environmental benefits to
plant-based nutrition
but i didn't have that kick myself i
just didn't feel like i could do it it
seemed too difficult it seemed
oh i don't know a bit pious and not
really me you know i had all these
preconceived ideas about what it meant
right this will mean that you're going
to end up carrying a picket sign
yeah and walking around angry
with birkenstocks on
well yeah no i just i think for me i
just thought yeah there were certain
stereotypes that i had
contributed you know sort of thought
about what it meant to be plant-based
what it meant to be vegan
and i felt that that wasn't my identity
at that time
so um
he did brilliantly and i thought well if
he can do so well just running a
marathon what could it do for health
what could i do for my patients i was
thinking about heart disease diabetes
cancer our biggest killers in the
western world could it make a difference
and i realized through
many years of reading that yes it could
i decided to jump in i did it myself
and i reap the benefits
my cholesterol went down i used to get a
lot of knee aches as well when i was
running
all through my 20s that stopped
so you know that's my own personal
experience but of course it's not um
that's not what i base my practice on i
have to read the research as well
but what i found was that it was really
beneficial for my patients and that's
when i felt you know the magic really
happened for me is when i could see with
my own eyes
the changes that my patients had
experienced and that fueled my passion
and i've been really passionate about it
ever since
so talk to me a little bit about
the transition from you experiencing
firsthand the benefits of this your your
blood panels improving etc
uh
and moving towards
then advising or advocating this
approach with your patients because
those are two different things yeah they
are two different things and i thought
long and hard before i started to talk
about this with my patients because
i knew that there would be
a burden of evidence if you like like if
i was going to be saying something to my
patients i needed to know that what i
was saying was evidence-based
and so it took me a lot longer to have
the courage really to to start talking
about it but
i think what many people don't realize
is that a lot of the data exists and it
has existed for a long time and it
actually forms the basis of a lot of
guidelines it's just that
we're perhaps not consciously aware of
that so the world cancer research fund
for example tells us that fruits and
veggies and whole grains and beans are
the cornerstone of a cancer-preventing
diet you know the american college of
cardiology talks about plant-based diets
for prevention of heart disease
um we have the american college of
clinical endocrinologists talk about how
it's really helpful for preventing
diabetes
and in the uk we've got the royal
college of gps they've got their
green impact scheme so there's actually
a lot of
sort of approval if you like from large
bodies um that are involved with disease
and nutrition
but i think still there is that
reluctance and a lot of people to to
really sort of take it in
well i think there's a couple things i
mean first of all there's this notion
that um
many
medical practitioners have that
that
lifestyle advice
doesn't really land with the patient
like i can tell them to do it but
they're not going to do it so i just
need to give them these meds and
tell them to maybe not eat so much or
you know some really general basic stuff
yeah but the reluctance is from this
place of
low adoption rates yeah i think yeah
you're right and
you have to believe that your patient is
capable of change i think in order to
start talking about it
and
that's hard because nobody likes to be
told what to do
and doctors like telling people what to
do
because i think you know we've done a
lot of training we want to make things
right we want to help people so we feel
like if only they'd listen to us then
you know right they would i think people
want their doctor to tell them what to
do though do you think so i think people
abdicate too much responsibility to
their doctor's advice in general i don't
know what it's like in in the uk but
in the united states
um a general practitioner like yourself
only has a few minutes with each patient
and so
there's not enough time to go into great
detail on all kinds of lifestyle advice
and there's no kind of follow-up or
accountability because those systems
aren't in place it's really just
diagnose prescribe move on to the next
person and it's not the fault of the
practitioner it's just the way the
system is set up yeah
do you feel that you in your practice
like have a little bit more bandwidth to
spend time with patients and
follow up with them etc because that
piece is so important to all of this it
is important and it's honestly the
reason i went into medicine and i think
that i do have a great advantage if i
think about it now because working in a
national health service
i have a patient list nearly 3 000
patients it's actually a really small
practice um it's equivalent to one
full-time doctor
so 3 000 people under my care
and
we have only 10 minutes so yes you're
right we do have a very short amount of
time it's not a great deal of time to
talk about lifestyle however we do have
the ability to bring people back we have
that sense of continuity
um because it's free at the point of
care and people don't have to pay
anything to see me and people can come
and see me as often as they want to they
just need to book an appointment so it's
very um
i'd say certainly compared to the u.s
it's very easy to book an appointment
there's still a lot of complaints um
generally in society about how easy it
is to get a doctor's appointment but i
think if we compare our healthcare
system to the one here in the u.s it's
much easier
and i'm able to offer that
accountability and also um that support
and that feeling of um
care that i think is really lacking
perhaps um when you're dealing with a
system where it's very much
drugs prescribed next you know so yeah i
do think i'd have a lot more freedom in
that respect
and
that's what i love about it i love
looking after my patients from cradle to
grave again it's slightly different
where i work because we deal with
everything we deal with pediatric issues
obstetric issues um elderly care issues
um
everything and anything people come to
us first whereas i think here they would
more likely go to a specialist in their
field um it depends yeah it depends well
yeah if you have something acute you're
going to find the specialist but for the
everyday stuff i feel like a lot of that
now is in these urgent care centers that
are all over the place so there isn't at
least from my experience and i don't
know what it's like for most people but
i don't have like a good relationship
with a single gp that i go to see that
kind of knows what's up with me
it's just if something flares up i go to
urgent care that that needs immediate
attention yeah and i think we're seeing
the disappearance of that patient-doctor
relationship because of the big hmos and
all that kind of thing yeah i see that
happening a little bit in the uk but i
think we still do have a lot more of
that relationship and i've got patients
have been with me i've been at that
practice now for 14 years
and i i've seen people grow up i've seen
families change um babies born yeah it's
nice
people yeah passing away and sort of
that whole cycle of life i've seen it
i've been there for it and i love it
that's why i became a doctor so
so you're going to see a little bit of
everything but i suspect the low-hanging
fruit or what you see quite frequently
are lifestyle ailments like you know
certainly obesity diabetes
and heart disease right which are kind
of the bullseye
problems that
a plant-based
plant-centric plant-predominant diet has
shown to be quite beneficial in
ameliorating or reducing the
symptomology and the underlying causes
absolutely and you're right that's
that's the bread and butter really of
what i see mostly high blood pressure
and diabetes
certainly in terms of chronic care
but you'll be surprised there's a lot of
other things that can also be affected
by plant-based nutrition which we may
come on to but
um i get a lot of people suffering from
hormonal health issues
endometriosis fibroids period pains
menopausal issues
and believe it or not those things as
well can be improved potentially by
eating more plants
and other issues bowel disorders i get a
lot of people with gastrointestinal
issues as well um so yeah there is quite
a broad range of things that can be
affected and it's it's lovely to be able
to implement that um
i don't necessarily manage to change the
diet of everybody that comes in sure
because people come with their own ideas
their own concerns their own
expectations but if they're open to
suggestions then yeah it can be really
special
is it a situation in which now that you
have this book out the plant bower
doctor right like oh she's the plant
power doctor like if i go in there she's
going to tell me to you know eat this
way like i don't want to i don't want to
deal with that i'm going to go to this
other doctor
i don't think i've had that yet you see
what i try and do with my patients is if
they're interested i'll refer them to my
website which is free and there's loads
of free resources on there so i don't
tend to sell too much but you're in the
media you're out there people know who
you are come on you'd be surprised in my
town i think people don't people don't
tend to sign up to me because of that
but a few of my patients have caught on
to the things that i'm doing online and
they follow me online so i do have to be
mindful of that right
um but yeah balancing the the public
version of yourself and the daily
practitioner version yeah it's hard
because you know i think people do have
certain expectations of what their
doctor should be how their doctor should
be right i don't want you going on
podcasts all the time you're supposed to
be like in the in the office like
looking at my labs
exactly right
exactly
um but no i think i've had mostly if not
all positive feedback and people have
been really inspired and it's been
lovely actually it's been a really nice
addition to my practice and one that
i'll be forever grateful for
because that's why i wrote the book you
know it was it was about kind of
widening my circle of compassion making
sure that people who wouldn't have
otherwise been on my list
know about this information in a really
accessible way you know there's it's
full color and pictures and flickable
and easy to access and it's got the
recipes too so it's literally i wanted
to make it
dead simple
well you achieved that it's a beautiful
book so congrats thank you um
you mentioned hormones uh a couple
minutes ago and and i want to get into
that
um people who have been longtime
listeners or or viewers of this show
uh know that i've had all manner of
whole food plant-based advocates on the
program medical professionals including
two recent appearances by our mutual
friend simon hill
and over the last nine years
i feel like i've covered most of the
issues regarding this lifestyle and the
role of nutrition and health generally
but one area that i admit to not having
covered with any particular focus or
intensity is women's health specifically
how this differs from general health
advice
and the role of food and hormones so how
do we find our way into this
topic i mean maybe start with some
thoughts about
when you say women's health like what
does that mean how is that different
from just human health in general and we
can get more focus from there
yeah so i mean i did do
extra qualifications in obstetrics and
gynecology obgyn you'd call that here
and
family planning as part of uh sort of my
my work as a doctor so for a while i
worked in family planning as well
and
i think it's not that women's health is
over and above different in terms of
nutrition to men's health but that there
are various considerations that we would
have
physically that that men
don't have um
now obviously
the most common thing would be the fact
that we have periods um
and we are kind of bound by that sort of
natural cycle from the age of
puberty to the age of menopause
menopause itself is a huge life
transition which doesn't occur in the
same way with men i think because
primarily because there's less of a
fluctuation in a sort of
steep decline in hormones relative you
know relevant to men's health it's more
of a gradual decline as opposed to a
precipitous one exactly it's much more
gradual and i think that helps to
ameliorate symptoms whereas for women
going through perimenopause um up to
menopause then you can actually have
wild fluctuations of estrogen it can go
way up it can go way down and that's
really one of the main things that's
sort of responsible for a lot of the
symptoms that women will get around the
perimenopause which we can i suppose
define
um but you know hormones affect men too
obviously they affect everybody there's
actually over 50 different hormones and
they have to work together in synergy
in order for us to perform at our best
and
it affects every aspect of our lives not
just puberty menopause periods fertility
but everything mood energy
our skin it affects
sperm counts um all sorts of things so
it's actually
integral to all humans but i'd say for
women there are a lot more
considerations especially around
um yeah the fact that we
carry children um and that we have
periods and that we have to go through
menopause which are very distinct life
phases that do require extra thought and
attention i think
and so what is the role that nutrition
can play in this
and
also lifestyle habits
so if we talk first about
um periods perhaps because that's
probably one of the main things that uh
women will focus on from
around about the age of 11 or 12.
um the
quality of your periods can change based
on the nutrition that you have so
periods are starting earlier which i
think is an interesting thing um i don't
think that's just because of extra
nutrition i think
there are also other factors at play um
with regard to
environmental pollutants and things like
that i think there's a lot of reasons
why
girls are starting their periods earlier
and that's really significant because
essentially that means that our our
growth is kind of done um we don't tend
to get much taller after we start our
periods um and i think
if you go through puberty and start your
periods too early it can put you at
increased risk of actually things like
heart disease at a younger age i never
heard that yeah which is a really
interesting thing um
and i think there's just a lot of extra
hormone exposures in our environment
that we haven't been able been able to
consider before so
meaning like environmental toxins toxins
in
skin care products etc
uh in our foods that are
dysregulating our natural hormonal
cycles yeah exactly and things that
mimic estrogens in our body
plastics for example phthalates bpa
they have hormone mimicking effects
which i think do affect things like
fertility and men's sperm counts but
also potentially also affect when young
girls and women start their periods so
yeah there's a lot to consider now that
we haven't really considered in the past
because they didn't exist
but i think in terms of practical things
that people can do
increased fiber is so important
main reason being that if you're
constipated you're actually potentially
recycling unwanted hormones through the
body hormones that you would have
otherwise got rid of um
you're actually reabsorbing so
trying to make sure that young girls and
well children and everybody in general
doesn't get constipated is quite a good
way of reducing our excess hormone
exposure
um
i think it's important to mention that
you know our fat cells in our body are
also hormonally active
they
can produce estrogen
so
if we have more of those then we also
have more exposures to estrogen as a
result of that which can affect men as
well as women but i think that's a
really important thing that that again
is not necessarily talked about much the
fact that our fat is also hormonally
active too
um
and
yeah so i think fibre is a really
important thing
it reduces our hormone exposures it
helps us to produce short chain fatty
acids which also are great for helping
our hormone regulation
feeding our gut microbiome which is
important as well for hormone regulation
which is also important for our immune
system which affects our hormone
regulation so all these things are
linked wait you're saying it's all
related i am
yeah i had uh dr dr b in here the other
day going going deep on fiverr once
again yeah of course um yeah and his
whole thing about you know eating 30
different plants and setting that as a
goal and
the importance of fiber for any number
of things and just how critical it is in
this conversation it it tends to get
lost we focus on macronutrients or
protein or
you know uh
our omega-3s all of which are important
of course but
most people
are fiber deficient like where's the
again back to the low hanging fruit like
what is the
quickest easiest change that you could
make that could have the biggest impact
and increasing the fiber in your diet
seems to have just a multiplicity of
downstream health benefits it does and
there was a study
uh i think it was actually led by dr
neil bernard um looking at how this
could affect people in their periods um
and they had a two-month
cohort of women um half were on a
healthy plant-based diet the other half
were a control group and they wanted to
see could it affect their periods and
what they discovered was that it did
make
a statistically significant difference
in the length and that the heaviness of
the women's periods and also just by
increasing fiber yep just by increasing
fiber and it also showed a raised shbg
sex hormone binding globulin which is an
important protein that essentially holds
on to hormones until we need them it's
kind of like a storage molecule if you
like
and what's interesting is it was able to
increase that for the women who are
consuming a healthy plant-based diet
which is important because that can help
regulate their unwanted hormone exposure
as well and is that a function of just
an increase in plant foods
and by definition an increase in fiber
or is there an aspect of that that has
to do with the removal of the the
meat and dairy products
it could be a bit of both so this is
postulation based so that study didn't
say specifically why but we know that
fiber is so crucial for reducing
recycling of hormones as i mentioned but
also
meat and dairy does have a role to play
with regard to hormone exposure itself
so
you know when we consume dairy we're
consuming the milk from a cow who's been
pregnant and obviously is lactating
which has
extra hormones bio
equivalent hormones to human hormones um
but also
in the meat that we eat
there is some hormonal exposure there as
well but also interestingly i think is
that meat is one of the main ways that
we get um potential for microplastics
exposures which are also affecting our
hormones um i think in the uk phthalates
are highest in fish in the u.s
phthalates are highest in chicken
and there is some data to show that
there was an association between
increasing meat consumption and
increasing um endometriosis symptoms so
maybe maybe define dilates and then
endometriosis i'm not sure i even know
what endometriosis is okay so let's do a
little backtrack endometriosis is a
condition that
could affect up to about 10 of women and
it takes many years often to diagnose
because the women who are suffering from
endometriosis just think that perhaps
they've got really heavy periods
but it's so much more than that so
what it is is where the womb lining
tissue
which normally just grows in the lining
of the womb and is shed once a month
with your period
starts to grow in other parts of the
body
we don't know why this happens it
predominantly happens in the pelvis so
you get that tissue that grows in the
lining of the womb in other parts of the
pelvis often sticking perhaps to bowel
or to the bladder
and but interestingly you can get
endometrial deposits anywhere even in
the brain very rarely
or in the lungs
and the problem is when you have your
monthly bleed
those uh cells will also bleed
and when they do they cause irritation
and inflammation so no matter where they
are in the body they start to bleed yeah
they will bleed and it can cross the
blood brain barrier yeah
very rare um but yeah it's mostly around
the pelvis or you know deposits perhaps
on the outside of the womb
um but the problem is that inflammation
and irritation then causes um a lot of
pain and it can cause parts of like the
bladder or the bowel to stick together
it can affect fertility it can cause
painful sex um
it's you know it's a really
sort of far-reaching condition
and you know if women are suffering from
horrendous period pains you know nausea
vomiting have to take days off work
painful sex problems getting pregnant
this is not normal and they have to go
to the doctors because many people will
think oh it's just my period but
interestingly you know periods
periods can be really painful um more
painful than a heart attack actually in
some some research tells us that they
that the pain of having a period because
um it's because of the prostaglandins
that are produced by those wound lining
cells
so you know when you're having a bleed
these prostaglandins that that cause
contraction of the of the womb that's
what causes the pain and and the you
know the
cramping um those sort of feelings of
nausea if it gets if the prostaglandins
get into the bloodstream that's what
causes you to have things like diarrhea
and vomiting nausea
it's it can get really bad and i think
you know women
don't always sort of know how to
advocate for themselves you know people
think oh it's just her period well
actually for a lot of women they really
do suffer
and especially when you have
endometriosis which is a whole other
condition
related to your periods um but causing
so many more complications so
so it goes on it goes undiagnosed often
because people just think you're having
a severe
period episode or you're ignored and
just
considered to be normal yeah so you know
either doctors will think oh she's just
having a heavy period i'll give her some
painkillers or she'll think oh i'm just
having a heavy period i'll just have to
wait a few days later it'll be okay but
for some women
you know it's completely life-changing
and
it can have a huge impact and as i say
up to 10 of women have this condition
and is there a test for it and then once
it's diagnosed how is it treated
so
this is why it's hard to diagnose
because the main way of doing so is
through a laparoscopy so you have to
have an operation essentially to see
those deposits which are usually in the
pelvis right which no one's going to do
unless it's so severe exactly so people
will try and you know muddle through
they might take some painkillers and
hope for the best but actually it's
really important to get that diagnosis
because once you have a diagnosis
one of the main ways of treating it is
is um to actually kind of blast those
little deposits burn them off
and that can help to improve fertility
and pain
but i would love for women to know that
diet and lifestyle can have an effect on
endometriosis as well a positive effect
and having a healthy plant-rich diet
could
improve symptoms um greatly
so yeah i i would love
for if there's one message for this part
of the podcast it would be for women who
have endometriosis to know that
hopefully if they have a more
plant-based diet they could see some
improvement in their symptoms
interesting um but they don't quite know
what causes it and there isn't any kind
of like simplistic cure
no there's no simplistic cure um but i
suspect that our extra hormone exposures
in the modern world play a part um just
because as i said there's an association
there between
the consumption of certain animal
products and the development of further
endometrial deposits and we don't yet
know i'd love for there to be more
research it's the same with fibroids i
would love there to be more research
into fibroids well let's talk about that
define what fibroids are okay
so fibroids are
essentially growths in the womb
and they are estrogen dependent so much
like endometriosis which is
um
in a way fueled by estrogen exposures so
is um the
development of fibroids and
you can get extra painful periods again
with fibroids without realizing it so
you'd be thinking oh i've just got a
heavy period but actually the reason
that you've got it on this occasion is
because your fibroid mass the lump is is
pushing against the womb lining which is
causing it to increase in the surface
area then it bleeds more then the period
is heavier
so not all fibroid lumps push into the
womb lining sometimes they can grow on
the outside of the womb or in the middle
of the womb
but for the ones that push onto the womb
lining they cause extra heavy bleeds and
you know if the fibroids get big then
they also have just a mass effect in the
pelvis which can you know affect you
know the way that you pee or the way
that you're able to pass motions so it
can have other downstream effects as
well
and again i would really love to see
more research into the causation and
amelioration of fibroids but suffice to
say in terms of lifestyle there are some
things that we've seen could be
associated with it
again we come back to the meat
consumption
that can have an impact on the growth of
fibroids perhaps because of the extra
estrogens or
plastics that we're exposed to
alcohol is another one that has been
associated with fibroids
physical exercise has been something
that's potentially been associated with
less severe fibroids but we just have
association data really so
i'd like to see more of it
and is there a test to know whether you
have fibroids or if you have them you
just know it
you don't just know it unfortunately but
you can get a scan that's much easier to
diagnose fibroids because you can just
you can arrange for an ultrasound scan
and you'll be able to see those lumps
there sometimes with a scan you can see
what could be endometrial deposits so if
you have an unusual appearance to your
ovaries
it could be something called a chocolate
cyst because um you get sort of dried
old blood then on the ovary itself which
looks like you know a sort of a dark
cyst and you can sometimes those cells
have blood because they've blended
period yeah exactly exactly
um so you can kind of get a hint of
endometriosis through a physical exam um
if you know if you're if your primary
care physician or your ob gyn has done
an internal exam you can sometimes get a
feel for whether that endometriosis
there based on um whether the womb or
the ovaries
feel fixed when you do an internal exam
and you can again maybe get a hint of it
with an ultrasound but the only way of
truly diagnosing endometriosis is with a
laparoscopy but fibroids is much easier
because you only really need to scan
and the appropriate lifestyle
interventions for fibroids look like
what
well i'd say really focus on whole foods
healthy plant-rich diet number one
you'll be increasing your fiber so as i
said before reducing your hormone
exposure from your own body
you'll be hopefully helping yourself to
potentially reduce any excess weight um
and you'd be avoiding
xenoestrogens from plastics exposures um
as well so
that would be the main thing i'd say
exercise is important
interestingly uh there's some research
to show that certain things are great
for reducing the pain of periods which
can affect endometriosis and fibroids so
ginger and turmeric have been shown in a
couple of studies to be really helpful
in reducing the um amount of
prostaglandins that are being produced
at the lining of the womb so i mean
essentially if if we kind of figure out
this is this is why um oral
contraception can help periods actually
because
oral contraceptive pills um reduce the
amount of endome endometrial lining
cells that are produced which then
reduces the prostaglandins which which
is what causes the pain and the cramping
so yeah so contraceptive pills can help
with the pain anti-inflammatory
painkillers can help with the pain for
the same reason they reduce the
prostaglandins but if we wanted to go
sort of down a sort of a lifestyle route
then ginger and turmeric have been shown
in studies
to have the same benefits as
anti-inflammatory painkillers for
reducing period pains so on some level
this is a a disease of inflammation or a
disease that's exacerbated by
exposing the body to inflammatory
foods and
um environmental
factors right so it would follow
logically then that a diet that is
anti-inflammatory
in nature i mean it's good for
everything right
would be particularly good at
ameliorating those symptoms of of these
conditions yes i think so and
if we look at other hormonally driven
thing so not just endometriosis and
fibroids but also polycystic ovaries
again it's another condition that
affects fertility affects our periods um
but can also be improved using lifestyle
again it's not something that tends to
come up in these kinds of conversations
but pcos polycystic ovarian syndrome is
very much like diabetes in that it's
driven by insulin resistance
and insulin resistance can be improved
by using whole plant foods eating a much
more whole food plant-based diet
and so yeah that's another condition
that could potentially also be improved
using lifestyle
and have long-reaching benefits sure
so increasing your fiber
turmeric ginger what are some of the
other
anti-inflammatory foods that top your
list
well we've got to go for like
berries fruits vegetables nuts and seeds
tofu tempeh i think
soy beans have a terrible reputation
still unfortunately but they are really
good for hormone regulation
because not only do they contain all
essential amino acids but um they also
uh they contain a special kind of
phytoestrogen which is actually
beneficial
so
it's it's actually
more of a modulator
rather than something that is an active
uh pusher of estrogen if you like right
so let's let's like really underscore
that because i think what happens is
people hear soy they think estrogen you
spoke earlier about dysregulated
estrogen causing these problems
so without further inquiry it would
appear that eating something like soy
with these uh with these estrogen
compounds would be not a good thing
right so like be i want you to be like
really clear about
soy
estrogens phytoestrogens the differences
okay
so
soy contains phytoestrogens or estrogens
but it's actually what we call a serm a
selective estrogen receptor right and if
you're british you say estrogen yes
um so it's selective in its action so if
you
um
so so what it does is if you are wanting
to reduce your risk of breast cancer
it's really great for that because it
blocks the receptors that are
responsible for um you know breast
cancer if you want to improve your bone
health it's actually really good for
that because it's more likely to
selectively bind to the receptors that
are in the bone area of the body so it
has selective effects which are actually
beneficial in terms of our hormone
exposures it stops us from being exposed
to bio-equivalent hormones and instead
blocks those so it's good for
reducing risk of breast cancer
especially if you start to eat soy
products young in life so for you know
young girls teenagers
young women there is some evidence to
show that if you have soy products
in childhood and adolescence it's much
more likely to reduce your risk of
breast cancer later in life but if
you're a dude or a mate
and you get on the soy early you become
a soy boy and develop man boobs
well you're probably more likely to
develop man boobs if you drink actual
cow's milk if you think about it because
that's bioequivalent estrogen but
in actual fact there is data to show
that soy can potentially reduce the risk
of prostate cancer
so you don't need to worry too much
about soy or in fact you don't need to
worry at all about soy
is there a difference between
um
soy
or tofu versus
um like tempeh or a fermented soy like
i've always understood that a fermented
version is is better yeah i think there
are different uh qualities i suppose um
interestingly soy products have been
shown to be beneficial for um
flushes sort of period flushes vasomotor
symptoms in women
um
so yeah but in in sort of japanese
populations they don't really have the
same amount of flushing and it's thought
to be because they have a lot of
fermented soy products sort of miso and
tempeh and
edamame beans and not that that's
fermented but it's a more natural form
of soy yeah but yeah
i think if you go for minimally
processed sort of tofu
tempeh
edamame beans miso soup that kind of
thing are you going to have
perhaps even better benefits but yeah
what about natto have you had natto i've
not had it but i've heard it's
disgusting i've heard that as well
it's atop the list though of like the
most nutritious fermented soy product
and it's an acquired taste that they
enjoy in japan but is not necessarily
readily available in the west no i mean
yeah maybe i'll try it one day but i
haven't tried it yet it's it's sort of
the the soy version of dirt of durian
right like but actually durian's
delicious yeah but it's an acquired
taste i mean durian's a hardcore thing
yeah i mean the people that love it
really love it yeah but it's it smells
quite strong though for sure for sure
but i actually wanted to say before we
get off the topic that interestingly
going back to the gut health md and his
passion for the gut microbiome
the effect of soy
on flushes and things like that can be
affected by our microbiome or easter
balloon so some people unless we have
the gut bugs to um sort of process the
genistein from the isoflavone in soy we
may not necessarily get the same
flushing benefits which is why it's
great then to have an overall plant-rich
diet because what you're doing there is
you're promoting the kind of gut bugs
which would then hopefully be able to
metabolize the um the components of soy
that benefit us in terms of vasomotor
flashing right so if you have some form
of dysbiosis
that could be a causal factor in a
dysregulated
um not
a dysregulated hormonal state and also a
dysregulated period right or some kind
of period issue yeah potentially so yeah
i'd say the bottom line is that plants
are always good in terms of hormone
regulation
and they can help to foster the
microbiome that could potentially then
also use other parts of plants to then
benefit us
how do you think about when you when
you're advocating a plant-based
lifestyle how do you think about the
difference between
a plant-exclusive diet versus a
plant-predominant diet as somebody who's
seeing a lot of patients and
for many i suspect this is like a new
idea
how do you communicate around that and
what is your kind of general position on
that yeah my general position is i just
want people to eat more plants
and i don't tell my patients to go vegan
because i think we do have a lot of data
that you can have a very healthy
plant-rich diet without necessarily
going 100 vegan
i am somebody that identifies as vegan
but it's not something that i would say
my patients have to do
i think that um from what i've seen the
more plants the better and we see that
in the data as well the more plants we
eat the better so it doesn't have to be
plant exclusive
but plant predominant is definitely
important for overall health and i just
you mentioned sort of low hanging fruit
earlier that's kind of how i feel about
it right now you know only eight percent
of what most of people in the western
world eat is fruits and veggies it's
more than 50 processed foods so if i can
get people more on those fresh whole
plant foods and less on the processed
foods then that's a win
so yeah that's how i tend to advocate
for it at work with my patients um
because not everybody's going to feel
100 ready to just dive in yeah um
so yeah have you had any patients come
to you who are on the carnivore diet
i haven't no
is that a thing in the uk because it's
like quite a thing here in the states i
know it's a big thing here and it's
getting more popular in the uk but you
know what if i'm honest i've only really
seen it in online and in wellness
circles rather than in my actual
patients i think instinctively most
people
feel that having a meat exclusive diet
could cause long-term issues
so how dare you i'm sorry to say
no but i think yeah it's not been
something that i've actually experienced
in my patients but
it's a tough one because in my practice
i never like to say to people that
they're doing something that's wrong
because we all have different paths to
health
having said that
it's really hot it's really hard because
you know people sometimes feel great on
a carnival diet to start with you know
they may have got rid of a lot of health
issues that they were having in the past
and for me
i think that probably comes down to a
fairly um strict exclusion diet
basically taking everything out which is
fine for short term but it's not really
something that you could consider
long-term health yeah that that argument
gets used against the plant-based diet
as well like oh you feel better when you
went plant-based because you just got
off all the processed foods but it's not
sustainable and over time you're going
to be
nutrient mineral and vitamin deficient
yeah it's a shame that people say that
about plant-based diets because
the way the way i see it based on the
research is that you know the
plant-based diet is abundant in
nutrients
as long as you're choosing a large
variety of fruits veggies whole grains
beans nuts seeds tofu tempeh all of
those incredible ingredients you're
going to get everything that you need
except the b12
but again i think the the health
benefits that i've seen in my patients
in the short term and the long term and
what we see in the data as well show us
that a plant rich and even a
plant-exclusive diet is brilliantly
happening
what about the argument i'm sure you've
seen this at least online that plants
are toxic that they have toxins that
they've developed as natural defense
mechanisms and that makes them
intolerable to the human body have you
heard that one i've heard that one
online again not with my patients
i think it's i think a lot of extreme
ideas tend to come from online spaces
and perhaps i don't know
why that would be but i think if we if
we look at the properties of plants yes
they do have certain
um sort of phytonutrients that we
benefit from but the toxins idea i think
is actually something that is really
damaging because often it's those plants
so-called toxins that provide us with
really important factors for our own
health because our bodies can use them
in ways that actually help us to support
our microbiome and our immune systems
so i think that's the difference between
perhaps mechanistic data and actually
seeing what people do in real life and
seeing what they eat in real life for
longevity and health which are two
sometimes completely opposed ideas when
everything comes together when
mechanistic data and observational data
and randomized control trials all come
together pointing to one direction we
can feel a lot more confident whereas if
we're just looking at a single trial or
a mechanistic trial on an animal for
example we're not going to really have
the same picture
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering 10 off an
annual membership when you use the promo
code rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right let's get back to the show
let's talk about menopause
yeah so
what is it and
what can women do who are experiencing
it um reduce the the symptomology around
it
i'm actually really glad to talk about
menopause because
i think it's something that many women
feel that they can't talk about it's
weird it's like this weird like it
happens to every woman right but it's
this sort of not really shameful but
like something that oh we just don't
talk about it yeah and i try to think
about where that comes from
i do think that we live in a patriarchal
kind of society that
really values women for the way that
they look more than
the way that they contribute to the
world
and
i think a lot of women feel that if they
talk about menopause that their
significance in the world is diminished
somehow that their function to produce
children
is
is gone therefore their worth is gone
that's that's something that i've
noticed a lot
certainly in my patients but also in
general society that people feel really
um reluctant to speak up about it and um
quite low about it like it's it's
something that a lot of women feel uh
that they've lost something about
themselves and i'd really like the
conversation to change
because
i think that if we can have an
empowering idea about what menopause can
do
then it can hopefully help women to
actually feel that they're even more
contributing to the world in ways that
they couldn't do before you know there's
only very few mammals that have a
menopause this is really interesting
um there's three mammals that experience
menopause obviously humans are one of
them do you have any idea what the other
ones could be well i would think it
would be
chimpanzees or apes you'd think so right
but actually it's not don't tell me it's
dolphins
nearly really whales it's yeah it's
orcas and pilot whales wow orcas pilot
whales and humans
so bizarre i would have just presumed
that every mammal
every every female mammal experiences
that no and this is significant because
what it tells us i believe is that we
have a very specific purpose
past our reproductive years you know we
have a very specific
survival advantage in having a menopause
whereas every other mammal does not
and there's actually something called
the grandmother hypothesis which
essentially tries to explore this
and the idea is that
the reason that humans have menopause is
because
women in society
have such value in in making sure that
we continue as a species and we maybe
look after younger children we would
bring families together we would bring
communities together
and there's a very strong survival
advantage to having women exist past
their reproductive years and i think
that should be celebrated because it's
something very special so yeah right the
idea that evolution has has prioritized
this because when the village expands
and there's more women around to
caretake for the many young ones then
everybody benefits as a result everybody
benefits and there's a survivor i think
that would that would be the case with
chimpanzees and apes and all other
manner of mammals as well yeah you think
so but it's interesting because when you
look at pilot whales and orcas they have
a very matriarchal society don't they
they they go around in matriarchal pods
and it's the grandmother that makes sure
that the mother and the babies are all
together and protected so right so we're
off the rails here being a patriarchal
society right we're we are
evolutionarily meant to be a matriarchal
society
okay
i think so that's my hypothesis
yeah interesting yeah um so
this occurs in in in every woman at a
certain age uh and it can i'm you know
those symptoms range in severity they do
and that's another interesting thing is
the symptoms can
range in severity based on where the
woman lives in some to some degree so
that i mentioned japanese women and vaso
motor flashes i mean that's one of the
main symptoms for
women certainly in the u.s and the uk is
um hot flashes or flashes
whereas interestingly japanese women
don't tend to experience that um there
was some anthropology work done um in
two provinces of india that showed that
menopause brought about increased
quality of life in those women because
they were
able to achieve more status they were
able to spend more time with men they
had
they had more of a say in the household
over the sort of the sons and the wives
and other younger children so in actual
fact when there were sort of um
questionnaires to those women they had
an increased quality of life and far
less menopausal symptoms
and what is the
i'm trying to understand what that's
attributable to the increase in quality
of life
yeah i think that
a lot of the symptoms of menopause can
be dreadful but also that um the society
in which we live if it's more supportive
to women going through menopause can
dramatically reduce um the effect on our
lives so um when you have
a society that is supportive or where
the woman is considered to be
a value wise contributing then it can be
actually quite empowering and it can
hopefully potentially lead to less in
the way of symptoms that's not to say
that it's all psychological no there's
some very physical and very real
problems but i think it's important to
just be aware that
in society and the way that we view
women
is really important because it can
affect our long-term happiness it can
affect the way that we feel we can
contribute to the world and that can
also affect the symptoms that we
experience much with any kind of medical
or health condition that's fascinating
yeah the social environment and a
supportive social environment can
can have that kind of impact yeah and it
just seems to appear that that's it
it seems to appear that way and it's
true for all sorts of things
there was a really interesting study
that showed that
people who had
increased happiness scores
positivity a good sense of humor their
longevity was increased even when they
were living with chronic disease um so
you know i think the importance of a
supportive community shouldn't be
underestimated which is why opening up
this kind of conversation is really
important so that men and women can
understand how to support
the third of women that are right now
perry or you know post-menopausal it's
huge so
so yeah um i mean that dovetails into
the blue zones discussion and the
importance of connectivity and community
and and and and and also of course like
holistic health like how we think about
these things which we can put a pin in
but sorry interrupted you continue yeah
i know well i was just going to sort of
start talking about some of the symptoms
which
again are not that well known apart from
the flashing or the flushing right
because women don't tend to talk about
it too much
but it's been married to julie for
over 20 years
and i know about the occasional hot
flashes but beyond that like i i'm
probably like a lot of guys like i don't
i don't really know what's going on yeah
it's it's it's okay but it's good that
you can be more aware and hopefully we
can sort of expand on that now and all
the men who listen to your podcast can
hopefully right i mean i want to yeah
this is about women's health but it's
also about like
helping men understand these things so
that they can be more empathetic to
their partners if they're in partnership
with women um and learning how to like
communicate around it in a positive
manner it's true in fact i i think that
rod stewart said that
if more men knew about menopause there'd
be far less divorces
[Laughter]
so do tell so i will so we've got the
vasomotor flushes which can be really
debilitating for some women where you
just have this tremendous heat going
through your body top to bottom
um sweat like crazy
tends to happen a lot at night as well
but it can happen at any time of day
vaginal atrophy is a big one um and it
doesn't just mean that that you have
soreness or um
some sort of dryness there it can
actually be quite severe for some women
so vaginal atrophy occurs when your
estrogen levels are going down
and it can cause painful sex and dryness
but also it can cause
severe burning itching like it can hurt
to sit down um it can it can if you had
an episiotomy scar when you were from
when you were giving birth they can sort
of come open they can split and bleed
like it can be a really severe problem
but again there's very little talked
about but can really impact the quality
of life
mood changes can be quite severe
increased anxiety is very real
and many women will put it down to oh
i'm just depressed they may think that
they need an antidepressant but actually
it could be that the hormone changes
around menopause are responsible for
some of those changes in mood
body aches this is a really interesting
one many women don't realize that severe
bone and muscle pain can be attributable
to those hormonal changes up to 30
of women going through menopause get
body aches but they won't always
attribute it to those changes in
hormones
which is another big one
dry skin
dry eyes some women only experience
severe dry eyes which
can again be very debilitating you know
ever having to use drops not be able to
see properly um it can actually really
impact quality of life as well
low libido your sex drive can sometimes
go down
understandably if you have vaginal
atrophy but sometimes there are other
things attached to that as well with
regard to um identity and you know
feelings of worth and attractiveness to
your partner that there's all sorts of
other things that can sort of uh play a
role there
so yeah there's quite a lot of different
symptoms um you are more likely to get
constipated because there are estrogen
receptors
that are in the gut so you have reduced
gut motility which then has an impact on
again um your hormone regulation
you because of the lack of estrogen your
body tries to come back to balance and
so you get metabolic changes as well in
the western world about 65 percent of
women have obesity because of the way
that the fat deposits more around sort
of the center of the body
as a way of trying to compensate for the
lower estrogen that's been produced by
the ovaries because as we talked about
earlier fat cells can produce estrogen
so again these are things that a lot of
women don't necessarily realize are
related to those changes in hormones
bone loss
so
unfortunately from about 40 onwards
we'll lose about half a percent of our
bone mineral density but when you go
through menopause
that drops precipitously
many women will lose about 20 of their
bone mineral density in the first five
to seven years after menopause wow and
that causes you increased risk of
fractures yeah that's that's very
significant yeah it's really significant
so i think that this is a public health
issue
and
i think that if more women knew
that the time around menopause
can be a time of empowerment
then they could actually potentially
prevent further problems so
hrt or hrt is something that again we
don't tend to talk much about but is
a really replacement therapy hormone
replacement therapy it's a really
important thing to open up a
conversation around
because it's one of the number one
treatments to ameliorate a lot of these
symptoms in women who are eligible and
who want to
and including things like bone mineral
density loss and heart disease risk as
well
and i think there's a lost generation of
women who felt that it was too dangerous
to even consider hrt
and in those women i think you know
there's a huge injustice that has been
done there
because hrt as a hormone
replacement model is
a great way to ease that hormonal
transition rather than going through all
those fluctuations you're replacing a
lot of the hormones that you would have
otherwise lost and you're
maintaining your bone mineral density
you can improve a lot of the bone ache
issues
you're actually reducing potentially
your risk of heart disease as well but
there is a window of opportunity with
regard to heart disease risk and that's
like around the menopause like if if
you're within 10 years of menopause or
less than the age of 60 that would be a
good time to
reduce your risk of heart disease moving
on in life
and the same with the bone mineral
density loss there's that window of
opportunity there in that sort of five
to ten year window between sort of you
know 45 50 55 where if you are eligible
it's worth at least exploring the idea
of hrt right
okay so with that in mind then
what
wait hold on a second let me collect my
thoughts before i start
we're talking about hrt right
so with that in mind
how safe or unsafe is hrt in general now
and what are the factors that determine
whether a woman is a is a good candidate
for this
yeah so there will be certain women that
are not eligible for hrt uh primarily
those who've experienced breast cancer
but there are other potential reasons
why they wouldn't want to have hrt as
well
obvious things like pregnancy or
a recent blood clot or an undiagnosed
bleed for example
but in actual fact i would say
excluding those women
most women would be pretty good
candidates for hrt
uh the main
problem that really scared a lot of
women
back in 2002
was the
women's health initiative study which
showed that there was potential
increased risk of breast cancer in fact
the study was halted early over concerns
about excess breast cancer risk
and
unfortunately the headlines around that
study went around the globe and made the
use of hrt drop by about 66
in other words the headlines being
something along the lines of hrt will
cause breast cancer yeah exactly and
it's scared it scared everyone it scared
doctors it scared women who were taking
hrt
so many women stopped taking it but
interestingly professor langer who was
one of the main investigators as part of
the study wrote a paper condemning the
headline of the study as being
irresponsible and wholly inaccurate and
many of the lead investigators on that
study were not consulted before it was
even published and
one of the main problems with the study
was that they used women age 65 or
thereabouts and they were starting hrt
brand new and of course by that stage a
lot of those risk factors for breast
cancer and excess risk of heart disease
for example were already in existence
before they began the treatment
and
it's i do believe it's let down a whole
generation of women there was a really
interesting study in the bmj from 2012
that showed that
if you take hrt for a period of five
years
you actually have reduced risk of heart
attacks and heart failure there was no
increased risk of breast cancer or blood
clots at all
and there was an interesting study by
david katz actually in 2013
and he estimated that in the 20 years
after 2002 uh that there were anywhere
between around 20 to 90 000 women who
died prematurely from not having access
to hrt because of the protection it can
offer for heart disease and bone mineral
density loss as well as obviously all of
the other symptoms that we've talked
about you know with the flushing and the
mood changes and the way the vaginal
atrophy and the way that these things
can impact their lives day-to-day
and the optimal time to begin hrt would
be early in menopause right before
you've already suffered bone loss and
all these other
ramifications yeah and it's i mean the
age of menopause does vary the average
age is about 51
but it's normal for it to start anywhere
between ages of 45 to 55.
um and i think it's it's actually vital
to think about if you're going to think
about starting it then because
you are
preventing it's a prevention isn't it so
you're preventing the bombing or density
loss you're preventing the
atherosclerotic plaques that we start
forming because of the lack of estrogen
in the body and how that's cardio
protective
um and it's it's a way of then you know
essentially lengthening your
time where you're sort of functional and
you're not having some of these problems
yeah and
what is the composition uh like what is
the hormonal composition of hrt so it's
basically a combination of estrogen and
progesterone
interestingly if you have estrogen-only
hrt then there's absolutely no excess
risk of breast cancer at all but the
reason that progesterone is often added
is to help protect the womb lining
because if you have a normal womb and
you just give unopposed oral oestrogen
then you could have
excess risk of bleeding and increased
risk of endometrial cancer which is why
progesterone is given in combination
with the estrogen replacement
but
if we look at i mean there's loads of
different types and formulations of hrt
but i do want to stress that if you're
going for like the gold standard which
would be an estrogen gel or an estrogen
patch
alongside micronized progesterone
then
taking that for about five years there
was a there was a systematic review to
say that there was absolutely no
increased risk of breast cancer at all
so
i'd love for women to know that that if
they want to look into it they should
it comes as i say in the form of patches
gels tablets
and
yeah there's loads of different brands
but essentially it's just estrogen and
progesterone
and what percentage of women currently
are on hrt is it a low percentage it's
low and it's increasing gradually i
think it was probably at its lowest just
after the 2002 study
um it's gradually creeping up with a lot
more awareness now about menopause and
the symptoms
especially in the uk i don't know if
that's translated over here um in such
in such a big way but
i i get lots more women coming to me in
clinic asking about hrt which i'm really
pleased about because so many women over
the years said oh it's not natural it's
not for me um
and you know it's harmful i'm worried
about breast cancer
and you know i want women to know that
it's a it's a very valid option and it's
actually you know it's the menopause
guidelines suggest that it's the number
one treatment for bone mineral density
losses
yeah you mentioned the word natural it
there is an interesting thing within
wellness and holistic health circles
that
you know obviously are going to
prioritize natural remedies
food is medicine etc
at the cost of medical interventions
that could be helpful right so there's a
weird you know in the venn diagram
between evidence-based medicine and you
know lifestyle protocols and the kind of
organic wellness alternative
holistic health
i could see a tension between those two
things like somebody who's like well i'm
just going to eat organic food you're
saying yes but this intervention could
be beneficial but hey that's not really
part of my protocol i'm trying to like
not be on any
any kind of exogenous
interventions yeah and that's something
that i respect
if someone doesn't want to take extra
hormones and they shouldn't have to and
i completely understand that perspective
i think what bothers me is the idea that
the choice of women is often taken away
because of unfounded fears and i think
for me it's important to be able to
offer something that could benefit and
whether women want to have it or not is
up to them
but we have to consider what's really
natural i guess in the environment that
we're currently living in i mean you
could say it's natural
to die in childbirth because if you're
in afghanistan and you know you're in a
village somewhere you've got about
a one in 14 chance of dying from
childbirth is that natural yes i suppose
it is but it's clearly not something
that anybody would wish to happen
and so i think you know when it comes to
severe menopausal symptoms but also
longevity
i want to be able to provide women with
every possible option that is deemed to
be healthy and appropriate and
if they want to take it they can right
you mentioned earlier that
the age at which
young women are experiencing their
period is getting earlier and earlier
is there also a change in the window for
menopause like is that happening earlier
also
no so i think it may it may be again a
reflection of western society and the
various exposures that we have but
menopause in some cultures is actually
seemingly getting a bit later
there is some potential genetic
differences as well
afro-american women
will potentially african or should i say
i don't know what you say here
african-american african-american black
women there are some potential genetic
differences in when you would start the
menopause anyway so for example
black women may find that they start
their periods on average about 48 49
whereas
white women may start one on average
about 50 51 but yeah i think menopause
can vary based on diet as well there was
an interesting study to show that eating
more vegetables
could potentially bring the age of
menopause slightly younger
um again not dramatically like maybe
three months on average so they were
looking at sort of large population data
but i think that's very interesting
because again it speaks to the effect
that our diets can have
on our normal physiological processes
is there a mode of eating or particular
foods that could
lessen some of the negative symptomology
around it
absolutely and i'd say again
i'm going to bang on about fiber fiber
is crucial
and soy
minimally processed soy products are
really beneficial as well
making sure that you have a nice variety
of things like nuts and seeds for extra
minerals like selenium are important
even sort of things like i know we
haven't touched on thyroid function but
again that's another hormonally
regulated organ you want to be able to
make sure that you're having great
sources of iodine selenium zinc and
that's true for all of the hormones in
the body but especially things like the
thyroid and what are some of your
favorite foods that are high in those
things so with selenium you could just
have like a brazil nut a day that would
be pretty good but it's also in whole
grains um whole grain rice whole grain
bread
other nuts and seeds and the same with
zinc as well
which again is important for things like
sperm production i know we're not
talking about men but
we're going to get to that
yeah so um there are loads of great
foods so just think fruits veggies whole
grains beans soy products i'm a big fan
of flax seeds just because they're great
at helping to improve the suppleness of
blood vessels and
um yeah they've got loads of great
omega-3s from plant sources as well just
make sure you grind them first otherwise
they pass right through yeah exactly
um let's talk about male hormonal health
is is you know is manopaws like a real
thing and also you know i'm interested
in your thoughts on on trt because it's
obviously the other side of that coin
yeah so i think that for men i mean i
don't have personal experience of this
but certainly with my patients it
doesn't seem to be as much of a thing
for men as for women and i mentioned
earlier i think it's because it's a very
gradual decline like with most of the
hormones in our body
testosterone production can start to
wane over time
so you know i think in certain
conditions it might be beneficial for
testosterone replacement but i don't see
it as being something um as vital for
male health as estrogen replacement
would be for female health based on the
changes in the body that occur for women
that just simply don't occur for men
yeah
i know so many guys
my age that are on testosterone therapy
um i'm not uh but
they talk about it you know it's
something that guys of my age you know
tend to are you doing that should i do
that should i not do that are there
negative health outcomes with respect to
that my understanding is that if you get
on it then that's it you have to stay on
it because obviously if you're taking it
exogenously then it's going to shut down
your body's whatever your body is is
making right like it's telling your body
like you don't need to make any of this
because you're getting it
yeah i think this is where men should be
cautious and speak to their own doctors
about whether it's necessary or not
especially if you're somebody that is
actually hoping to perhaps father a
child at any time because like you say
you're turning off your own testosterone
production there whatever you know is
still going on
and that can have ramifications for your
fertility
so i think that probably the main
consideration um depending on the
intentions of the person that wants to
take testosterone replacement just to
think carefully about if it could
actually impact their fertility
but
yeah most guys my age are pro they're
not worried about that part yeah
actually they want the opposite
not everyone but yeah so yeah it's it's
not something that is as prevalent or
indeed i don't believe as necessary for
men as it is for women
um but it's a conversation that i think
is occurring a lot more uh what would be
the reason for doing it
uh probably to
increase things like muscle mass uh
mood changes sometimes that can occur in
men um as as the testosterone levels
that you're endogenous endogenously
producing fall
um
yeah i think one of the main reasons
that my patients will go on testosterone
replacement is if they have um excess
estrogen exposures um so it tends to
happen more
um when men are carrying excess weight
as well that um because as i mentioned
before the fat cells can produce
estrogen which can have uh perhaps a
slight feminising effect
so yeah what else is unique to
male hormone health that you can speak
to
i think one of the main things that is
worth talking about for male hormone
health is um the gradual decline
or the gradual apparent decline in sperm
counts over the course of the last
couple of generations
and the increased rates of something
called hypospadias which is where the
urethra the the we tube
sort of forms and grows on the underside
of the penis
and the increased rates of
only having one testicle at birth
this is something that i suspect is
related to again the plastic exposures
in our environment the phthalates
exposures
um
i didn't know that that was a thing yeah
increase in men being born with one
testicle yeah what percentage of the
population i i don't know significant
enough that it's it's been it's been
noted to be increasing and
again as i said the hypospadias issue as
well where there's a sort of a
distortion to the penis as a result of
changes in um the exposures in the womb
basically because obviously this is the
way that the baby has been born
um and yeah i i do see that there is a
correlation there between that and
increased rates of exposure to things
like microplastics phthalates bpa
and it can potentially affect sperm
counts too so
simple things that i think men could do
that would be useful would be
i mean studies have shown that vigorous
exercise is quite good for sperm count
assuming that you're not putting too
much excess heat on the testicles
themselves because like for example with
cycling or hot baths because that can
have an impact on the sperm production
but otherwise vigorous exercise is good
sources of zinc and selenium as i
mentioned things like nuts and seeds are
really helpful coenzyme q10 again that
can come
through those kinds of healthy foods
nuts seeds whole grains
yeah and minimizing plastics exposures
generally
which i think probably the low-hanging
fruit would be to drink your water from
glass rather than plastic
to avoid um something that's come in a
plastic bottle if it's been sitting in
the heat
like in your car if it's a hot day for
example
and you don't know it could be in uh uh
you know in a cooler in the grocery
store but it had to be transported from
somewhere it could have been on a truck
for days or weeks yeah that's true
excruciating heat that's true we just
don't know getting rid of plastic i mean
it's so hard it's so hard it's so
completely ubiquitous i know and i'd say
it's almost impossible i think recently
there's a study to show that it's been
microplastics have been found in the
human bloodstream it's something that we
we can't escape at this point but we can
minimize and you know i i don't want
people to come away from this
conversation feeling scared i think i'd
rather they feel empowered to know
there's a few things that we can do to
minimize our overall exposure and that
would be
heating if we're using a microwave for
example then just put it in ceramic or
in glass as you heat it you know if
you're drinking water then drink it from
a bottle maybe if you can invest in a
water filter do so
simple things that hopefully will over
years accrue to benefits
what about the role of of dietary fats
and hormone health
yeah i mean interestingly i have read
data to say that saturated fat
consumption has been associated with
lower sperm counts in men so
that's something of interest
we also know that when you're eating a
high saturated fat diet then it tends to
be mostly from animal products and again
you've got those extra plastics
exposures and things that can affect
hormonal health from there so it's hard
to necessarily separate the two
but in a more general sense we have lots
of data to show that a saturated
fat-rich diet is very linked to things
like heart disease
um and public health campaigns can make
a difference
so you know
i know that there may be listeners that
think oh well you're only feeling better
because you're eating more whole foods
and it's fine to have things like you
know grass-fed beef and so on but if you
look at data from countries like finland
for example they they had the highest
rates of heart disease in the world back
in the 1970s they wanted to do something
about it they had a massive public
health campaign
many people reduced their red meat
consumption stopped smoking ate more
vegetables and then you know
moving fast forward about 20 30 years
they've managed to reduce the heart
disease rates by 80 percent
so we can see that these are basic
simple things that people can do that
can have tremendous impacts on our
health um moving forward right
within the whole food plant-based
community there's varying opinions about
um
the positive or negative
consequences of fats in the diet we have
the caldwell esselstyn
camp which is very low fat no oils
typically that protocol is is something
that's advised for people that are
experiencing heart disease or have
suffered some sort of arthrosclerotic
event
and then there's another camp of people
who
are saying that's hyperbole
uh a healthy dose of olive oil in your
diet is fine like how do you come down
on this you know hot debate like it's
very divisive it is divisive and i hate
divisive debates
so i try and stay out of them i don't
know if you noticed but i don't tend to
get into it online well i'm gonna put
you square in the middle of it right now
you're gonna have to state your position
okay so my position is we have to eat
more veggies as i mentioned before
that's the number one you're dodging
like that's a that's a dodge
if i ever heard one okay looking at the
data that we have i think it's fair to
say that if you're having
good quality olive oil with polyphenols
in it it can have some health benefits i
don't think that um
having olive oil in your diet is an
unhealthy thing to do
and i think a generally mediterranean
style of diet is known by many people
many nutrition researchers to be one of
the best ways of eating for overall
health which includes olive oil
um
yeah i i don't think that
for the majority of people having oil
here and there is going to be at all
harmful i'm not somebody that thinks
that seed oils are particularly harmful
either because you know they they are
rich in poofers and moofers
polyunsaturated fatty acids
monounsaturated fatty acids which we
know are
health and beneficial to health if
you're replacing
saturated fats in the diet with those
kinds of oils
so yeah i think
it's it's hard to sort of come down hard
and fast but i'd say looking at the data
that we have
trying to compare what you know one
thing to another seed oils have no
demonstrable
issues when it comes to heart health but
i would say that
if you are aiming to lose weight
then it's not a great idea to have a lot
of things like seed oils in your diet
because they're very calorific and they
don't really contain a lot in terms of
the nutrients that you'd be looking at
to help fill you up like the fiber-rich
foods would and also i have a certain
cohort of patients certainly that notice
when they have a lot of oils in the diet
that it can flare up things like
inflammatory arthritis
and i think it would be remit of me to
avoid mentioning that that certain
people
who have a whole food plant-based no oil
diet find that it's beneficial for
inflammatory arthritis as well as
potentially beneficial for heart disease
right and i would assume there's a
difference between raw olive oil oil
that you sprinkle on a salad versus
cooking with it like the oxidative
impact of high heat on some of these
oils that's a whole different thing it
is although i would say that the heat at
which most people cook at home is not
going to cause too much oxidation of
olive oil i think that's that's
something that's probably overstated
what is the oxidation
temperature point do you know i don't
remember rich you put me on the spot
there
i stumped you
you know every oil has a different um
smoke point yeah smoke point right so
coconut oil is much higher it is it
doesn't oxidize until you get super hot
so it's sort of advised that if you're
going to cook with one that's the one to
cook with well that depends because
coconut oil also contains saturated
saturated fat which is still saturated
fat even though it comes from a plant
so i think
if someone wants to concern themselves
with the smoke point then avocado oil um
is probably a good choice or
um
cold pressed canola oil would be a good
choice as well that's always been the
one the number one enemy one sorry but
the data suggests the data suggests that
cold-pressed canola oil is um a pretty
good oil to cook with because it
contains the you know the um unsaturated
fats and it has a higher smoke point so
yeah well if you don't want to cook with
it you don't have controversy
um
in the
in the daily practice of being a doctor
and seeing patients what do you find to
be
you know when you're in this discussion
around
changing your lifestyle maybe adopting a
more plant predominant diet
what and then following up with these
people like what do you find to be the
common
blind spots or or stumbling blocks or
places where people can go astray
i think
our food environment is probably the
biggest thing so
we seem to have this
feeling in the wellness space that we
are all individuals and unique and we
can make choices that are not unrelated
to other things in the world and
actually
most of the choices we make around food
are unconscious choices about i think
ucl research stated that there was over
200 unconscious food choices that we
make every day and only about 13 to 15
conscious food choices wow
and we know that we made that many food
choices in a day period well exactly but
that's what fascinates me is to think
when the research tells us that
so many of the factors that control what
we are actually out of our conscious
mind it's much harder than to make
changes for the long term that are
healthy especially if you don't have
the mental bandwidth or the budget to
think about these things having said
that
we know that whole plant foods can be
some of the cheapest things you can buy
as long as you can get access to them so
one of the main stumbling blocks for me
has always been
people's habits and
ability to have the bandwidth to make
those changes mentally
so i really start simple just go for
very simple swaps find their favorite
meals and make them with more plants
basically maybe get them to write down
their favorite things that they like to
cook and add more beans add more lentils
add more vegetables and then gradually
crowd out the other things um has been
one of my number one sort of ways to get
people to eat more veggies
yeah yeah i feel like it's it's
two main things one which you just
referred to
um which has a lot to do with
being more conscious about
the environment that you keep like if
you can create an environment where the
healthy choice is the most convenient
because you've cleared all the [ __ ]
out of your cabinets and you only have
healthy choices and when you wake up in
the middle of the night like sorry you
know it's gonna
yeah you know that ben and jerry's just
ain't there so it's about a conducive
environment to making the better choice
but i think perhaps even the bigger
issue in stumbling block is really the
social issue like people get all up in
their heads about what other people are
going to think about them what's going
to happen when they go to susie and
dave's you know dinner party and they
don't want to make a fuss or i have to
go on vacation with my neighbors and you
know it's just going to be too
problematic and people
like relinquish their boundaries or
you know are are just too afraid to to
stand up for themselves or to like make
that conscious choice
because they don't want to be difficult
yeah i can totally relate to that
because that was my instinct first of
all when i started on this journey my
main thought was oh this is going to be
so awkward for everybody people are
going to think this is so strange you
know it's i think as social creatures
it's one of the main considerations that
a lot of people have um and
i guess it comes down to
living in alignment with
the things that you most want
do you most want to be somebody that
pleases others do you most want to be
somebody that lives in alignment with
things that are important to you are
those things one and the same
if you can have a conversation with
yourself around the values that you're
living by
it becomes much easier to then make
conscious choices that are in alignment
to those values
so
i would actually encourage everybody to
have this conversation with their loved
ones or even just with themselves they
could write it down in a journal write
down their top values in life and how
their food choices can relate to those
values
and then it becomes a lot easier because
you're taking away
a lot of the extra choices that you're
having to make or the social situations
that you're having to navigate because
you are consciously living in alignment
with the things that matter
so if it matters to you to
minimize your risk of heart disease
because you have a relative that died
young you want to see your children grow
up then you write that down and you find
ways to make it work within that kind of
framework if you like your values
framework
if animal compassion is important to you
it's probably a lot easier because
you've already made that decision for
another outside purpose it's something
that's outside of yourself and perhaps
the same can be true for someone that
cares deeply about the environment and
the planet they've already made that
decision based on a value that's so
strong to them that it actually makes it
a little bit easier to stick to i think
health
overall is probably one of the first
ways people go towards plant-based
nutrition but it's also one of the
hardest ways to stick with it if that's
your only goal because it's quite
self-focused whereas if you can focus on
something outside of self then it
potentially could make those choices a
lot easier either environmental health
or animal compassion or reasons to stay
healthy for others
it tends to be in my experience ways
that make it stick a lot more yeah
that's that's a really good way of
thinking about it one of the questions
that i get all the time i'm sure you do
as well
is i want to do this but my partner
doesn't want any part of it and you
began this journey richard was doing it
ahead of you two different dinners meals
etc
but for a lot of
couples that becomes very problematic
especially when
those values might come into conflict
with each other yes you're so right and
i think my advice from that being the
partner that was most reluctant perhaps
i can speak to this more
if the idea that
what i needed
was um
was patience and time
and sometimes people will never come
around sometimes the people you love the
most will never want to do the things
that are important to you when it comes
to diet
and
i think that taking away that
expectation is important because when
you start to expect things of other
people that's where you can start to
become very unhappy you know you have it
builds kind of criticism in your mind it
builds comparison
it builds expectation and that can be
quite toxic for your relationship
so my best advice is just to do the
thing that's making you happy do the
thing that brings you in alignment with
who you want to be
and show your partner through your
actions how much happier how much
healthier and how much more abundant you
feel in your life and then if they want
to come along for the ride they can
right but you have to be
detached from that expectation otherwise
you're going to be vibing them all the
time and then that piousness creeps up
and that just becomes a disaster exactly
you've got to let that go
you just gotta let that go even if it's
in the back well if i keep doing this
they'll eventually come around they'll
it's no no you gotta like get rid of
that i i do think that that's probably
the best way for you to sustain a
healthy relationship with the people
that you love the most and it's hard
because often the people you love the
most may you feel need it the most
especially if they have a health
condition that could benefit from doing
that but you have to let it go because
it's not your life it's their life i
mean that's advice for this particular
scenario but for you know a zillion
others as well like in terms of like
partnership dynamics yeah and in a
partnership
you will often have expectations of a
partner that are unspoken
and that could be true for any kind of
scenario
and that's not to say that you shouldn't
communicate the things that are
important to you of course you should
but it's the expectation that is
attached to that which i think can
become very negative in in the
relationship
so
letting go of the expectations of your
partner is probably
the key to a happier life in all sorts
of ways did richard do that yeah he was
very patient with me
[Laughter]
in fact when uh at one point i think
because steak used to be my favorite
meal and burgers i'd always ordered
burgers when i was out and steak i loved
steak and once he even cooked a steak
for me that [ __ ] is how much he loves me
um oh
strategic yeah exactly it's like reverse
psychology right so it was in the back
ah if i do this
right yeah who knows uh but that brings
up an important issue which is
you know somebody who's listening to
this or watching it is thinking well my
life is just going to become infinitely
more complicated it means like we're
going to have to prepare two different
meals i'm going to have to spend all
this time in the kitchen i'm going to
have to plan out everything in advance
it's probably going to be expensive and
suddenly
my life which was kind of going along
pretty good suddenly gets hijacked by
this new lifestyle habit that is going
to commandeer all my time energy and
money
and is that the person that's wanting to
start this or is this the partner of the
person that's wanting to stay
it's the plant curious person who's
contemplating the change but now
suddenly feels like maybe this is a
little bit too difficult yeah so it's
kind of moving from contemplation to
action that people tend to have a
stumbling block right well they're
hearing you and they're like well my
partner's not going to be into this so
am i willing to
yeah do this thing that's going to you
know potentially cause
fissures in my relationship and you know
take up a lot of my time yeah and those
are valid very valid concerns and i
guess what i'd say to that person is
you have to find the thing that
helps you know
where you're going for the future i
think a lot of the time we kind of coast
through
and
we do things because they are the path
of least resistance
and
sometimes the path of least resistance
is a great path and it works and
everything's going well
but sometimes over the course of maybe
weeks months to years we start to notice
actually this isn't really working for
me anymore you know although this is the
easier route
i'm not feeling this i either don't feel
healthy or
there's something niggling me in in my
conscience about things i want to do
differently
and
sometimes changes do require a certain
amount of forward thinking and sometimes
the biggest changes that we make in our
lives are
as a result of pain points things that
come up in our lives that we don't like
hello yeah
exactly pain can be our biggest teacher
and
for those who are hoping to start making
changes but that pain point isn't quite
there yet then maybe they won't make a
change maybe this won't be the right
time for them
but my hope is that if we plant these
seeds together today
some people
will have enough water to plant you know
to water those those seeds and other
people may have enough sunlight to
provide those food with a little bit of
sunshine and maybe those seeds will grow
into plants of change sure based on
today so the person who's sticking that
seed into the soil right now and getting
ready to water it but doesn't know how
to water it like how do you think about
the the early phases of this like i'm
somebody who went all in that's just my
personality type i recognize most people
aren't like that i suspect you're
somebody who would counsel people to
make tiny changes master them like how
do you get somebody engaged in this
and give them some actionable advice
about how to begin in a very practical
manner so number one is literally write
down the foods that you buy in your
weekly shop
number two is write down all the foods
that you make with those ingredients
and if you can find
one meal a week that you'd like to have
more plants in then that can be your
first step is literally just cook one
meal a week that is plant-based and see
how you feel
and then if that works for you then you
can cook another one
and then maybe cook another one
yeah but all i do is eat take out
[Laughter]
well if you eat take out then
interestingly in the u.s i don't know if
it's the same but in the uk uh we have a
pretty good
plant-based
ready-meal range in a lot of our
supermarkets and interestingly i had a
patient who was elderly type 2 diabetic
never cooked for himself
and i said to him why don't you just
swap that one ready meal that you buy
for this ready meal which has all plants
in it um and in doing so he was able to
come off insulin and improve his type 2
diabetes so
there's always a starting point for
everybody if you're somebody that just
eats takeout then
you know what for you the best thing
would be perhaps just to start with one
home-cooked meal a week rather than
trying to change everything just cook
one meal at home rather than having all
meals take out um for my elderly patient
who
was just eating like small ready meals
from the supermarket switch to a
plant-based one and see how you feel see
if it changes your health over time so
it's just it is for a lot of people
about those baby steps yeah um
for others like you they jump in and
they'll get started and they'll figure
it out along the way and they'll enjoy
that process and that's great but for
most people it's just little steps and
you know there was research by bj fogg
to show that only one like one change is
enough to then start changing shifting
that identity and then sort of adding in
something new after that so yeah just
one thing one thing is all you need to
do
i'm getting bj fogg in here i've been
going back and forth with him on email
forever yeah he's getting in here soon
though um yeah i like that idea i mean i
think you know in listening to you i'm
reflecting on on some of my habits now
and what i find myself doing from time
to time when i'm busy or julie's out of
town or she's like i'm not cooking
tonight i go get plant-based takeout but
you have to be really careful because
when you're getting take out food you're
not preparing the food there's going to
be
more oil in it than you think there's
going to be more salt in it than you
think and if you're opting for some of
these uh meat and dairy analogs like
maybe not so good not all of them you
know they're all
it depends on what you know because
there's a there's a spectrum and
in terms of health you know the health
factors that are
you know what these things are about um
but how do you think about the you know
the beyond burgers and the impossible
burgers and all of that kind of stuff
i like to be fairly practical in the
advice i give to people i think if
somebody likes the taste of an
impossible or a beyond burger and wants
to have it once or twice a week then
there's no reason why they shouldn't for
the most part especially early exactly
in the transition but then having said
that you know there is interesting data
emerging that there was a study that one
of my friends did actually on a specific
brand of
plant-based meat replacement
meatballs and mints
and in the study families were given
these meat replacements to use alongside
the normal meat and other foods that
they would prepare
and what they found is that in the
families that had the meat replacement
they had a favorable change in their
microbiome over the course of those
i don't remember how many weeks the
study was but it was perhaps about four
weeks to my recollection they had really
great shifts in their microbial health
from using
meat replacement analogues so
i think
we do need more research to understand
the effect on the body but we do also
know that for you know in the majority
of these meat replacement analogues
there will be less saturated fat
um there will be less or no heme iron
which are both potential issues when it
comes to heart disease risk and
inflammation in the body
and you know
i think they are too easily demonized by
a lot of people um
and yeah that's that's my take on it i
wouldn't say you should have them every
day yeah but it's the same with any kind
of food it's great to have variety and
whole foods as your main go-to
but i think a lot of people are too
quick to um to cast off these meat
replacements right yeah well i again
it's a spectrum somewhat worse than
others yeah
and there's a difference between health
promoting and neutral versus deleterious
to your health exactly i think what what
is becoming
a bigger issue over time
is that
now there are so many products out there
that taste really good and you can kind
of psychologically rationalize eating
them like oh it's it's vegan it's
plant-based like it's got to be good for
me right
and and wake up only to realize like
you're you know you're eating french
fries and beyond burgers all the time
that's not a whole food plant-based diet
and it becomes incumbent upon you to
like really make sure that you're eating
plant foods close to their natural state
as wide a diversity as possible rather
than deluding yourself that because
you're not eating
cheeseburgers you're eating a plant
version of that
that so you know you're going to
sidestep heart disease right like
exactly so yeah and it's it's hard it's
kind of like the stuff finally tastes
good for the most part and it's going to
continue to get better and better and
better i think what we're gonna see is
like a split we're gonna we're gonna
have foods that are gonna taste exactly
like that thing but they're gonna be
probably on the more unhealthy side and
then there's gonna be other companies
who are creating
plant analogs to some of our favorite
foods that are doing it with health in
mind and lesser ingredients and and
natural ingredients and my hope is that
there's a lot of focus and energy and
money going into that right now because
i think that's what we need more of i
agree with you i will i think that
you're absolutely right we want
minimally processed less ingredients
more whole food-based
analogues for sure and the the
ingredients do vary really widely so
yeah
i think when you look at the data on
plant-based diets
and the healthy plant-based diet index
which was
really interesting data you see as you
pointed out that
if you're having an unhealthy
plant-based diet with things like you
know
french fries and
and um
ice cream and all the things that ice
cream and oreos and potato chips
yeah crisps potato chips all of that
kind of stuff
you're not going to reap the same
benefits at all and you're right people
can delude themselves i think oh well
it's healthy because it's plant-based
well it's not always so what's your day
and food look like
oh i love oh what do you call it here
oatmeal i call it what do you call
that's what that's what they call it and
what's your town called again where i
live yeah buckinghamshire right of
course it's like the most british thing
ever sorry okay
yeah and what part of england is it
surrey it's not i work in surrey i work
in syria and i live in buckinghamshire
which is kind of between
well i live sort of near windsor where
the queen lives so that's kind of near
where it is you'd probably just get more
regal i know with every moment gemma
well i'm from devon which is not as
regal that's down
by the sea yeah isn't that where
earthling ed's good like his fish his
plant-based fish restaurant is good
catch or something like that i don't
know but i'd love it if it was because
devon needs more plant-based options i
think it is i could be wrong but
anyways go ahead a day in the life oh
yeah so i forgot where i was going yep
so i love porridge i love to put flax
seeds and chia seeds in it berries
almond butter you've got a lovely
mixture of whole grains you've got your
nuts you've got your seeds you've got
your antioxidant rich berries so yeah
that's a real win for me
and yeah i i in my book i've got a lot
of wholesome recipes that are also kind
of comfort foods favorite comfort foods
like mac and cheese which obviously
doesn't have
um
cheese in but it's a nice kind of whole
foods version
uh i love things like spaghetti
bolognese but rather than using mints i
use uh lentils and beans
um minces like meatballs minces american
oh yeah no i i don't know do you not
have mints it's
m-i-n-c-e right that's how you're
spelling it it's sort of like ground
beef it's like ground beef right yeah
but i don't use it yeah we don't call it
that yeah what do you call it i don't
know crumbles
i don't know what we would call it what
do we what do we call it mints we don't
have a word for that
chopped meat yeah i don't know
there's lots of suggestions from all
these different corners of the room
yeah so i love i love comfortably
porridge i eat mince and porridge
yeah so i don't eat much mince at all i
just i tend to have like beans and
lentils with my spaghetti bolognese um i
like burritos actually i'm a big one
well you're in the right place for that
yeah i've seen yeah we had some amazing
burritos we went to cafe gratitude oh
you did i had lunch there yesterday
were you there no
today you were there
day before yesterday yeah yeah i missed
you no it's good there right yeah it's
really nice mm-hmm yeah do they have
burritos
in the uk yeah we do
[Music]
and what else
um
no that's not it i've got lots of things
i love um i love a good curry i've got a
great curry recipe in the book
cauliflower and chickpea curry i love
um
i also really like stews um
and that's kind of wholesome winter i'm
thinking of all my favorite winter foods
because we've had a very long winter in
the uk
but now we're coming into the summer i
do love things like salads i add in um
things like tempeh and tofu into my
salads
and uh what else
and is richard still the cook or you
cook also yeah i cook richard cooks a
little bit yeah cool well let's round
this out with maybe some practical
guidance to kick people
um
into this kind of lifestyle like when
somebody comes to you and they're ready
to go like what kind of words of wisdom
can you provide to empower them to
embark upon this journey with confidence
and perhaps a few you know practical
things that they could do to
make it work within the construct of
their busy life well i think the number
one thing is is think of simple swaps
that you enjoy
which we've already touched on number
two would be again to think about the
values that are important to you and
if you could try and live by those each
day it really helps you with the food
choices you're making as well as
everything else
maybe just three just three values that
would be really helpful
um i don't know if you have any sort of
top three that you have in your head
right now well i was just thinking if i
was you and i was seeing patients and i
knew that they could come back and make
another appointment and follow up i
would try to because i'm competitive i
would try to find a way to gamify it i'd
say like well here's your numbers in
these categories i want to see them go
down
10 in each so i want you to come back in
30 days
and and and we're going to do it again
so it's almost like goal oriented like
yeah it's very practical like here's
what we're driving towards
and if you can come back you know every
30 days or every 60 days or something
like that and we can evaluate the
progress that creates a level of
accountability and engagement yeah i do
that at work i definitely do and it's
quite nice because you've got actual
numbers to work with
and you have a goal for people to to
have in mind i think making making those
goals specific and time orientated
really helps
so i mean generally for people
at home if you want to do that for
yourselves then maybe you could get your
blood test done your blood work done and
then decide okay in the course of four
or eight weeks i'm going to get to this
number and this is how i'm going to do
it
but certainly in my practice i found
that with my patients getting average
blood sugar readings getting cholesterol
or lipid panel profile
or blood pressure readings actually they
can change over time as well with
nutrition it's quite nice to then be
able to have that accountability to be
able to bring them back and to encourage
them as well
yeah i think for some of my patients
then gamifying it is good but for others
they just tend to need that little bit
of extra like compassion and care and
you know
make sure that they know that i'm going
to be there and i'm going to check it
again when they come back so yeah it's
yeah good strategy i also think being
being specific
it's fine to say it's okay to do this
gradually but how are you specifically
going to accomplish that because you
just say well i'm just going to try and
i'm going to start eating more plants
seems very vague but if you say listen i
know you love cream in your coffee so
for the next 30 days you're gonna do
almond milk or soy milk or whatever it
is and you're just gonna master that one
thing like that's all you have to do is
like that one thing and it makes it very
doable because and it's it's it's kind
of like a go no-go thing right you can
wrap your head around it this is what
i'm doing
um and then after 30-60 days of that
it's like okay well that's just i don't
even think about that anymore what's the
next thing that i can do yeah exactly
and i think that makes it more like
because the human brain is weird right
and if you're just like well i'm just
going to eat more plants like what does
that mean right yeah i think that that
will wane in terms of how people are
kind of
consciously engaging with each meal and
each food choice that they're making
throughout the day yeah you're right and
it's also so individual to people as
well so i could have one person sitting
in front of me who thinks okay well i
can start with my milk
and i'll have someone else sitting in
front of me that thinks okay well i know
i can just start with my breakfasts and
i'll have someone else sitting in front
of me that thinks okay well i know i can
just start with two tablespoons of milk
flax seeds a day
okay and then so it really depends on
the person what route i go down yeah
based on what they feel they can achieve
based on what they already are doing
which is yeah it's quite good to
individualize it in that way and make it
really super specific i also think
people future trip
i'm sure they say to you i can't do it
because i have to go to a wedding this
summer you know in four months or
something like that it's like
that doesn't matter like this is a sober
thing it's like what are you doing today
can your head hit the pillow sober
tonight that's all you have to worry
about what is your next food choice when
you okay you're gonna go to the grocery
store today like what are you gonna buy
like just focusing on making that next
right choice and not worrying about what
you're gonna do tomorrow obviously with
food there is some planning involved
like you're getting food for the next
day or for the following week but to the
extent that you can just be rooted in
the moment and not freak out about like
the rest of your life or oh my god i'm
never going to have this food ever again
because i think that that really works
across purposes with the goal it's so
true that is so true and i think about
that in other aspects of of life as well
um you can generally manage to do
something just for today
you know you can you can manage to
make the right kind of choice for your
health and body just for today
or you can choose not to feel angry just
for today or you can choose not to worry
about something just for today
um
yeah and this is a slight tangent but i
actually have this daily mantra that i
do
which is exactly that
it's in japanese
and in english it means
just for today do not be angry do not be
worried
be grateful
do your duties fully and be kind to all
living things
and that is a mantra that i actually
repeat to myself twice a day every day
in japanese and it's just for today well
you know what i'm gonna say right now
i'm gonna make you do it in japanese
okay
oh gosh okay the fresh is on
kyo dakawa ikaruna
shinpai suna khan shashte
kyo o hagame hitani shinsetsuni
that's beautiful
i think that's a good place to end it i
can't imagine a better ending than with
that mantra
it's called the gokai the gakkai where
did you find that
it's part of my jikoden reiki practice
which is a whole lot of topical
conversations yeah that's a whole i i
know a little bit about that but that's
a whole other podcast yeah next time
next time next time but yeah it's a
great way of living being thinking you
don't have to put pressure on yourself
to be your best self every day just try
and do it today
the plant power doctor
paid a house call today and i think
we're all the better for it thank you
gemma thank you rich thank you for all
that you do i appreciate you the new
book is the plant power doctor available
everywhere pick it up it's a it's a it's
quite an accomplishment a beautiful book
beautiful photographs plenty of
recipes but amazing takeaways to improve
your life on the daily thank you so
i wish you well and come back and talk
to me again sometime i can't wait for
the next time i gotta make it out to
london yeah i'm trying to figure that
out at some point when you do i'll be
there we'll both be there we'll cook you
amazing food you can stay with us if you
want to excellent in in in
buckinghamshire in buckinghamshire i
just feel like i have to see it now
because in my mind there's you know
just you know beefeaters everywhere and
and you know no no it's it's um well
windsor yes we could take you to windsor
which is only a ten minute drive away
and you'll see beefeaters everywhere
there
good that's promise
um and final thing like if people wanna
to
learn more about you what's the where's
the best place to have them go
yeah you do a lot on instagram i do a
lot on instagram yeah plant power doctor
on instagram but my website's got loads
of free resources geminium.com
so yeah check that out as well all right
thanks
peace peace and plants
[Music]
you